[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور تاتينا من تل ابيب
وعوده الاحتجاجات ضد بنيامين نتنياهو
وحكومته وازمه التعديلات القضائيه
وهذه الصور تاتينا من مكه المكرمه حيث
اكمل حجاج بيت الله الحرام رمي الجمرات في
منى في ثالث ايام التشريق وتوجهوا لاداء
طواف الوداع لاخ اخر مناسك الحاج قبل
عودتهم الى ديارهم
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد خمسه ايام على بدء احتجاجات غاضبه من
مقتل شاب بالرصاص شرطي
تسع رقعه الاضطرابات لتشمل مدن اليوم
ومارسيليا
الى جانب باريس وحظر تجوال ليلي في 20
مدينه وزير الداخليه يعلن نشر خمسه
على التوالي ووزير العدل يتوعد من وصفهم
بالمحرضين على العنف في شبكات التواصل
وماكرون يرجئ زياره رسميه الى المانيا
احتدام المعارك في اوكرانيا يترافق مع جدل
بشان مسار الهجوم المضاد زيلينسكي يتهم
حلفاء غربيين بالمماطله في تدريب الطيارين
على مقاتلات اف 16
تقارير امريكيات تكشف عن زياره مدير السي
اي اي لاوكرانيا وبحثه استراتيجيه تكييف
في المعارك وعزمها بدء مفاوضات مع موسكو
بنهايه العام ووزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
تقول ان وفدا عسكريا صينيا بحث في لندن
الوضع الاوكراني
بعد طلب بولندا نشر اسلحه نوويه امريكيه
ضمن برنامج استخدام مشترك للنيتو ميدف
يقول ان اي نشر لاسلحه نوويه هناك يعني
استخدامها وبالتزامن مع تحذييرها من سباق
تسلح النووي غير منضبط الخارجيه الروسيه
تدافع عن قرارها نشر ذخائر نوويه في
بيلاروسيا
يقول ان الغرب هو من يضع راس اوروبا تحت
المقصله النوويه
قصف مدفعي متبادل في نيال غربيه السودان
الجيش يكثف غاراته على مواقع الدعم السريع
في الخرطوم وبالتزامن مع تحذيرات بشان وضع
المنشات الصحيه اتهامات للدعم السريع
باستهداف مستشفى الشهداء وقتل احد الكوادر
الطبيه وقوات الدعم تنفي
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعتذار ملك هولندا عن ارث
بلاده الاستعماري وتحديدا في ماساه
العبوديه هولندا كانت ثالث اكبر قوه
استعماريه في العالم يوما ما وسعبدت اكثر
من 600 الف شخص
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي لماذا ترفض
بعض الدول الغربيه الاعتذار عن ارسال
الاستعماري وجاءت النتائج كالتالي
48% قالوا ان ذلك بسبب مخاوف من عبء
التعويضات بينما رجح 17% وجود مخاوف من
الادانه الاخلاقيه اما 35% فاعتبروا ان
بعض الدول الغربيه تسعى للاستمرار في
الاستفاده من المستعمرات السابقه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقيه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
قال مراسل الجزيره ان السلطات الفرنسيه
اعلنت فرض حظر للتجوال الليلي في نحو 20
مدينه
بضواحي وضواحي باريس ياتي هذا مع استمرار
الاحتجاجات لليوم الخامس في فرنسا حيث
اتسعت لتشمل مدنا اخرى بينها ليون
ومارسيليا وسراسبورغونانت هذا وشيع
ظهر اليوم جثمان الشاب الفرنسي ذو الاصول
الجزائريه الذي قتل برصاص شرطي في حين
ارتفع عدد المعتقلين الى اكثر من 2000 بعد
ليله جديده من اعمال العنف المتواصله في
جميع انحاء البلاد في المقابل تدفع
السلطات الليله بعشرات الالاف من عناصر
الامن في محاوله لاحتواء الاضطرابات
الليليه
بحضور جموع غفيره وفي اجواء مهيبه شيعت
جنازه الشاب نائل الذي قتل عند حجز امني
للشرطه غير بعيد من هذا الحي بعضهم قدم من
احياء وارجاء بعض المدن والبلديات
المجاوره مشاعر الحزن امتزجت بالاسى
والغضب مع الاصرار على المطالبه بالعداله
للضحيه
لانها جريمه عنصريه وقد قتل بدم بارد لانه
من اصل مهاجر من قبل شرطي يعرف القانون
جيدا كان عليه ان يعطل اطارات السياره
نطالب الرئيس ماكرون بانصاف عائله الضحيه
وان تتوقف هذه الجرائم فنحن
جدا وهذا المفروض لا يصدر من دوله تتبجع
بالديمقراطيه كفرنسا
حتى على حقوق الحيوان فما بالك ان شاب
بريء في ريعان شبابه يقتل بارد مراسم
الدفن جرت بعيدا عن اعين الصحافه بناء على
طلب من عائله القتيل
دفني الشاب نائل اسئله كثيره يتردد صداها
في فرنسا هل سيصغي المحتجون الى دعوات
التهدئه سيحدث مزيد من التسعين تساؤلات
تتداولها الاوساط الشعبيه والسياسيه بينما
بدا القلق يكبر لديها مخافه عدم القدره
على احتواء رقعه المواجهات
تتولى الليالي وتتجدد المشاهد ذاتها وكان
ساحتها بلد يعيش حربا اهليه
فعلى ايقاع مشاهد العنف والتخريب قضت عده
مدن فرنسيه ليله اخرى من المواجهات
هذه بعض اثارها حرائق وتخريب للممتلكات
ومواجهات بين المحتجين وقوات الامن
[موسيقى]
السلطات احصت وفق حصيله مؤقته اكثر من 30
هجوما على محافظات للشرطه وتكنات للدرك
واتهمت النيران مقر عده بلديات ومدارس
ومحاكم وكما حدث منذ بدات المواجهات اكتظت
الشوارع بالسيارات المتفحمه غليان قررت
السلطات التعامل معه بمزيد من الحزم حتى
لا تنفلت الامور من عقالها
يجب ان اقول انه عندما لا يمارس الاباء
سلطتهم الابويه وهذا يعرض للخطر سلامه
الاطفال واخلاقهم وتعليمهم فيمكنهم تحمل
عقوبه يكون الحد الاقصى لها سنتين في
السجن بالاضافه الى غرامه قدرها 30 الف
يورو
احداث ينظر اليها على نطاق واسع على انها
نتيجه لعقود من التهميش والتمييز طال شباب
الضواحي وازمه قد يكون اليمين المتطرف
اكبر المستفيدين من تبعاتها نور الدين
الجزيره باريس
وعد وزير العدل الفرنسي ايريكاد من من
سماهم المحرضين في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي قائلا ان الحكومه ستصل اليهم
ودعا دوبون موريتي خلال زيارته لاحدى
المحاكم في ضاحيه فالديماري دعا شبان
الفرنسيين الى الامتناع عن ما وصفه
بالانسياق لدعوات التخريب عبر شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي
من جانبه قال وزير الاقتصاد الفرنسي برونو
مار ان الحكومه قررت استئناف عمل خلايا
الازمه في مختلف في مدن البلاد لمتابعه
الاوضاع واوضح في مؤتمر صحفي بعد لقائه
ممثلين عن اصحاب المحاله التجاريه
المتضرره من الاحداث الاخيره
250 فرعا من فروع البنوك تضررت بسبب ما
سماها اعمال التخريب واضاف ان شركات
التامين وعدت بتقديم تعويضات للمتضررين من
اعمال النهب الاخيره مشددا على ضروره الرد
عليها بكل حزم
ولم يستبعد وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيرال
درمان اللجوء الى اعلان حاله الطوارئ لكنه
ربط ذلك بتوجهات الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون وقال في حديثين التلفزيوني ان
الرئيس سيقرر ذلك في ضوء تطور الاحداث على
الارض واكد الوزير الفرنسي ان الجمهوريه
ستنتصر على من وصفهم بمثير الشغب والعنف
خلال خمسين عاما فرضنا حاله الطوارئ اربع
مرات في احداث خطيره فعلا مثل ازمه
الارهاب واعمال الشغب في عام 2005 اريد
التذكير بان الرئيس شيراك استخدمها بعد
عشره ايام من حصول اعمال الشغب كما لجانا
اليها خلال جائحه كورونا نحن فقط لا نريد
استبعاد اي فرضيه وقد قال الرئيس ماكرون
ذلك وسنرى بعد ليله الجمعه ما سيقرره
من جانب اخر اعلنت فرنسا والمانيا اليوم
ان رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ارجى
زياره رسميه لالمانيا كان من المقرر ان
تبدا غدا الاحد في ظل الاضطرابات التي
تجتاح فرنسا في الوقت الراهن
ينضم الينا من باريس غابرييل
الاستاذه في جامعه باريس وايضا باريس
جيرالد اوليفيا الباحث والمحلل السياسي
مرحبا بكما ابدا معك سيد جابرييل
عندما نسمع تصريحات المسؤولين لليوم
الخامس على التوالي في عمليه توصيف ما
يجري في فرنسا
هل يلامسون حقيقه الموضوع هل يضعون اصبعهم
على الجرح كما يقال
[موسيقى]
تفضل به هذا التقرير فهو قدم الاحداث بكل
دقه بالنسبه لرده فعلنا حول الحكومه في
اخر
احداث هو انه محاوله التنقل من المسؤوليه
حتى ان الرئيس تحدث عن مسؤوليه العاب
الفيديو وهذا غير صحيح في ازمه من هذا
النوع الامر معقد يجب ان ننظر في الحاله
الطارئه والحاجه الى التفاعل مع
الاعمال العنف ولكن اذكر ما قاله مارتن
لوثر كينج قال ان عنف الصيف ما ردوه وعدم
التحرك في الشتاء هذا ما يحصل في فرنسا هل
يعني الازمه انطلقات بسبب عمل عنف قام به
شرطي تجاه شاب الجزء الاكبر من الشعب
الفرنسي متاثر بذلك ومتضرر ولكن هذا امر
طبيعي ما نعرفه من
على مر العقود في ثقه مختلفه وان العنف
كما نرى حاليا في عمل الشغب او في اي عمل
عنف اخرى
مرضها شعور بعدم مساواه ليس الفقر
الناس يشعرون بانه ليس هناك مساواه مع
غيرها لهذا وعدم انقله السيد جيرالد سيد
جرالد الى اي درجه تتفق ما قاله السيد
جابرييل
ويعني هذا يضاف الى اننا نرى كل ازمه
اجتماعيه الضواحي لا يمكن الا ان تشارك
ايضا
بكل ازمه اجتماعيه تشهدها فرنسا لماذا
برايك
يجب اننا شكرا على الاستضافه طبعا مساء
الخير اولا يؤسفنا ان نكون منفعلين حتى
الان اليوم حصل جنازه هذا الشاب ولم نصل
الى مرحله التحليل مرحله التحليل تاتي حين
يعود الهدوء ويبدو هذا المساء انه بدا
يعود انا في باريس انا اتيت الى
استوديوهات الجزيره وكانت شوارع في باريس
هادئه الليله حصلت حوادث ليله امس في عدد
من المدن خارج باريس ولكن بصوره عامه
بالتحديد كما اشرتم هناك مشكله في بعض
الضواحي في فرنسا هناك مشكله حفظ امن عام
ونظام عام
وتقبل هذا النظام العام
والذين يعيشون في تلك الضواحي كانوا
متناسين هذه الاعمال الشغب لم تحصل او
للمره الاولى
الى مليارات اليورو من الاستثمارات في
الخدمات الاجتماعيه خدمات النقل الصحيه
المدارس والتعليم في عدد كبير من هذه
المواقع وهذا لم يحل المشكله لم يحل
المشكله لان احدى مكونات هذا المشكله التي
نرفض ان اراها هي للاسف الهجره واتحدث عن
دمج عدد او فئه من هذه هؤلاء الاشخاص
حين نرى ان وفاه هذا الشاب وظروف محيطه به
ادت الى تعليقات من قبل
اذا في الجزائر في فرنسا نتحدث عن مشكله
الجنسيه لدى عدد من الاشخاص وهناك عدد من
الاشخاص او عدد من الشعوب التي تعيش في
فرنسا وهم يرفضون ووضعهم ولا يحبون فرنسا
لا يحترمون النظام الجمهوري يحاولون ان
يفرضوا نظام
يبدو بانك يعني اشاهد انت تسمع للسيد
جيرالد وتهز راسك بالنفي الى اي درجه هناك
تعبر وجهتي النظر لديكما عن انقسام حتى في
رؤيه المجتمع الفرنسي لهذه المشكله
وبالتالي يعني هناك حلقه مفقوده حقيقه في
نقل حتى ما يجري من ضمن الاوساط النخباويه
الى الحاله السياسيه
ترفض هذا الشرح الذي يرد الامور الى
الهجره نحن لدينا مشكله معقده لا يمكن ان
نجد لها سبب سببا واحدا انا ايطاليه الاصل
وليست مساله هجره او عدم هجره ما يحصله هو
ازمه تعليميه صرفت الكثير من الاموال في
الضواحي ساتحدث عن هذا الموضوع انا كنت
اعمل في هذا الضواحي لمده سته اعوام في
مدرسه كان هناك مشاكل عنف خطيره واليوم
انا ادرس في جامعه كما اسلفتم اقول لكم
ليست نفس الحياه داخل باريس او خارج باريس
الحديث في فرنسا غير صحيح كذلك ليس صحيحا
انه يتم هجران
اهمال الضواحي هناك عمل في الدواحف ولكن
اذا كان هناك
شبان يسعون لتدمير هذا يعني لانه هنا او
هذا يعني ان هناك رشيد دين لا يهتمون بهم
اذا لم يكن الاهل موجودين او
يعرفون العمل كيف يمكن ان نلوم الاطفال
الاساس هو التعليم لا يمكن حل المشكله الا
بالتعليم سيد جبريل يعني عندما يستمع مثلا
سكان الضواحي مثل هذا الخطاب الذي يصمهم
مثلا بانهم يعني يميز يميزهم عن باقي
السكان على الاقل
ويشعرون بالتهميش وحاله عدم الاستثمار في
التعليم لديهم
ويجري ايضا بالمقابل استخدامهم وتوظيفهم
ضمن الحملات الانتخابيه هل تعتقد بانهم في
النهايه سيستمعون الى السياسيين عندما
يخاطبونهم وسيصغون اليهم
اريد ان اقوله بالنسبه الى ما سمعته من
السيد لاتانسو ما هو محيط به هو انها ليست
مشكله مرتبطه بالهجره فقط هناك مشكله
مجتمعي امنيه قضائيه
[موسيقى]
ثقافيه وفي الحقيقه مشكله تعليم
وسياسات التي نعيشها منذ خمسين عاما هي
سياسات
تسعى دائما الى عدم القاء لهم على احد
تعتبر ان الجميع هو ضحيه ومن هنا
بطريقه ملائمه وهذا ادى الى ضياع هؤلاء
الشبان والشابات ليس لديهم مرجع عائلي
وبالتالي يكونون تحت رحمه قائد الشارع
المؤثرين حتى عصابات المخدرات ايضا هي
دوامه مفرغه ليست فقط
لانه كان اكثر عمليه بالنسبه لسياسين ان
يعطوا بعض المال ومن ثم يطفلون الق
ضيه يهتمون بشيء اخر على امل ان لا ينفجر
الوضع باستمرار ما نلاحظ في كل عام اعمال
شغب تحصل نمر بها كل عشرين وثلاثين عاما
او منذ 30 عاما عفوا نرى ان الشورتين
يصيرون اكثر ردك لما سمعته من السيد دعمنا
وايجابي ولكن بالنسبه الي هذا مجرد كلمات
حين تواجه فرنسا هذه المشكله فعلا ستفعل
ذلك ولن تكون الامور بسيطه لست اكيده من
ان حكومه اليوم فعلا قد قررت ان تفعل ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك من فارس جورالدو اوليفيي
الباحث والمحلل السياسي وايضا ضيفي من
باريس غابرييل
الاستاذ في جامعتي باريس
تظهر استطاعه الرائيه ان عموم الفرنسيين
لديهم نظره سلبيه للضواحي وسكانها ويعتقد
اغلبهم ان هذه الضواحي هي مناطق خطيره في
المقابل يشتكي سكان الضواحي من التمييز في
السكن والتعليم والخدمات وفرص العمل
ويتهمون السلطات الفرنسيه باهمال مناطقهم
والاعلام والسياسيين بتحميلهم كل مساوئ
البلاد
ارقى المحلات في شارع الشونزيليزي بباريس
تضع متاريس خوفا من وصول محتجين اليها هنا
يسود الخوف من وصول ابناء الضواحي
الغاضبين من قتل الشرطه مراهقا منهم يلخص
المشهد حاله شرخ تعيشها فرنسا اظهر
استطلاع اجرته ستاديسكا عام 2017 ان 80%
من الفرنسيين يعتقدون ان الضواحي مناطق
خطيره يؤكد خبراء ان هذا الشعور المتضخم
بالخوف من الضواحي يرجع في جزء منه الى
تركيز على مشاكل الضواحي واختصارها في
الهجره والارهاب والحجاب وانحراف الشباب
ويغذي السياسيون لاسباب انتخابيه في
الغالب هذا النقاش الدائم يسمح في فرنسا
اكثر من غيرها من دول الغرب بالاسلام
فوبيا التي تستهدف سكان الضواحي واغلبهم
تعود اصولهم الى مستعمراتها السابقه في
شمال وغرب افريقيا الان وفي خض الاحداث
اظهر استطلاع لقناه السينيوز ان 70% من
الفرنسيين يؤيدون ارسال الجيش لاستعاده
النظام في الاحياء التي تشهد اضطرابات
يحمل تاييد الغالبيه ارسال الجيش الى
مناطق داخل فرنسا دلالات كبيره عن النظره
السائده لهذه الضواحي حسب احصاء نشره
راديو فرنسا عام 2019 تتشكل الضواحي من
1500 حي تقريبا في عموم التراب الفرنسي
يعيش فيها اربعه ملايين وثمانمائه الف
نسمه ما يمثل سبعه في المئه من سكان
البلاد
منذ ثمانينيات بدات تظهر مشاكل في الاحياء
التي تم تجميع المهاجرين الذين جاء بهم من
المستعمرات بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لاعاده بناء فرنسا اكتشفت فرنسا انها
ارتكبت خطا بتجميع هؤلاء المهاجرين في
احياء تحولت الى احزمه الفقر بدات بعدها
السلطات الفرنسيه سياسه المدينه لتقليص
الفوارق بين الضواحي وباقي مناطق فرنسا
لكن الارقام اليوم تؤكد ان هذه السياسه لم
تحقق النتائج المرجوه حسب الاحصائيات التي
نشرها راديو فرنسا فان اربعين في المئه من
سكان الضواحي يعانون من الفقر اليوم
مقارنه ب 16% فقط في باقي مناطق فرنسا
بينما تصل نسبه البطاله في صفوف الشباب
الى اربعين في المئه في بعض الضواحي تفسر
هذه الارقام حاله الغضب التي يظهرها ابناء
الضواحي الذين يشتكون من التهميش ومن
انعدام المساواه في التعليم وفرص العمل
ومن الوسم الدائم بالجريمه والانحراف
[موسيقى]
اتهم رئيس الاوكراني فلودي مرزلينسكي دولا
غربيه لم يسميها بالتقاعس عن تدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين في الاثناء تتحدث
وسائل اعلاما امريكيه عن زياره سريه لرئيس
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليامبرز الى كييف واجتماعه بالمسؤولين
الاوكرانيين بشان سير المعارك في الجبهات
اما في لندن فقد قالت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه نوفا من وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
زارها وبحث الملف الاوكراني الى جانب
ملفات اخرى
تقييم البينتاجون لمسار الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد ووصف رئيس الاركان مارك ميلي له
بانه سيكون صعبا وطويلا تقاطع مع تقديرات
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين بان الهجوم يواجه
تعثرا وتحذيراتهم من مغبه تباطؤه اذا لم
تحصل كييف على مزيد من السلاح في هذا
السياق يتهم الرئيس الاوكراني فلودومير
زيلينسكي بعض من وصفهم بالشركاء الغربيين
دون ان يحددهم بالمماطله في بدء تدريب
الطيارين على قياده طائرات اف 16 تمهيدا
للحصول لاحقا على المقاتلات الامريكيه
التي قد تحدث فرقا في معادله المعارك
الجاريه اتهام الرئيس الاوكراني جاء خلال
لقائه في كييف رئيس الوزراء الاسباني
مشيرا الى عدم وجود جدول زمني واضح لمهمات
التدريب
من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء الاسباني ان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي قدمت حتى الان مساعدات
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 12 مليار دولار
وفي وقت سابق قررت دول في النيتو البدء في
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين وزيره الدفاع
الهولنديه قالت ان البرنامج التدريبي الذي
تدعمه واشنطن سيشمل بلجيكا والاكسون بورد
كما عرضت فرنسا وبريطانيا المساعده يضاف
الى هذه الدول الدنمارك التي تحدثت مصادر
اعلاميه عن بدء تدريبها الطيارين
الاوكرانيين في هذه الاثناء تنقل واشنطن
بوست عن مسؤول امريكي ان مدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه ويليام بانز
زارا كيف سرا واجتمع بزالينسكي وكبار
مسؤولي الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه واستنادا
الى الصحيفه فان المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
كشفوا للمسؤول الامريكي عن استراتيجيتهم
لاستعاده ما تسيطر عليه القوات الروسيه من
اراض والبدء بالتفاوض مع موسكو بنهايه
العام
ينضم الينا من لندن
كبير محللي برنامج روسيا واوروسيا في
المعهد الملكي للشؤون الدوليه تشاتسام
هاوس مرحبا بك معنا هناك تملم الغربي واضح
من نتائج الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
بالاضافه الى التشكيك في امكانيات احداث
فارق خلال الفتره المقبله بالمقابل هناك
ايضا شكوى اوكرانيه من نقص في تزويدها
بالمعدات كم منوعا وتدريبا حتى ما هي
المقاربه الاقرب لواقعيه ما يجري من وجهه
نظرك
الجانبين
واحدهما من الاخر الغرب مستاء ولكن هذا
مرضه الغرب اوكرانيا محقه واشارت الى ذلك
انه بدون دعم ومعدات ملائمه من الغرب لا
يمكنها ان تحقق
هجوما مضادا فعالا وسريعا هذه الانذارات
التي سمعناها من اوكرانيا على مر اشهر لان
هذا ليست مشكله جديده هي كلها صحيحه وفي
محلها وهل ترى بانه يجري الان العمل من
قبل الاطراف الغربيه والاوكرانيه على حل
هذه المشكله خاصه مع مع وجود تعويض غربي
واوكرانيا على اهميه الانجاز على الارض
كما يقولون من اجل الذهاب الى المفاوضات
بصوره اقوى
الكثير من الادله التي نراها من الخارج عن
الحلفاء الغربيين بالنسبه الى رؤيتهم
نتيجه اعمالهم يرون هذا البطء في تقدم
اوكرانيا ولكن لا نراهم يتحركون لتصحيح
ذلك سريعا اذا هي مثبت النبوءه ذاتيه
الغرب الذي اراد ان يدفع اوكرانيا نحو
المفاوضات يتردد في توفير الاليات
والانظمه العسكريه الان بعد تباطؤ هذه
الجهود الاوكرانيه يضغطون بعض او يجدون
انه من الاسهل دفع اوكرانيا الى التفاوض
كان في اوكرانيا وبحث سير المعارك مع
القاده الاوكرانيين هناك هل تلتقي
الرؤى الامريكيه من وجهه نظرك مع الرؤى
الاوكرانيه
حول اهميه الانجاز على الجبهات والذهاب في
نهايه هذا العام لاتجاه التفاوض مع الجانب
الروسي
للاسف ما نراه هو بالنسبه الى تحالف
الغربي مع اوكرانيا هو اختلاف الاراء حول
كيفيه نهايه الحرب
والاسوء هو انه داخل في الولايات المتحده
حتى هناك اختلاف اراء وتضارب اراء حول
افضل مسار للمستقبل هناك جزء كبير من
الاوساط الحكوميه تعتبر انه يجب التوفير
لمساعدات الى اوكرانيا سريعا لان هذا افضل
اوروبا ولكن من جهه اخرى لدينا قوى داخل
الحكومه الامريكيه تقول لا يجب التفاوض
على التسويه ولا يجب على اوكرانيا ان تضغط
بعيدا هناك توتر بين الجانبين هو الذي
يعرقلوا ارسال المساعدات وبدانا نرى نتيجه
ذلك وتبعاته ماذا وراء زياره الوفد الصيني
العسكري لباريس ومن ثم الى لند ن وتصريحه
بانه بحث الملف الاوكراني مع الجانبين ترى
ما هي المواضيع وضمن اي سياق يجري بحثها
ضمن الملف الاوكراني
عددا من مبادره السلام تقسيم من دول
مختلفه الصين قدمت واحده من الابرز
بالنسبه الى اوروبا كل هذه المبادرات تعرض
نهايه الاقتتال بدون حل فعلي وهذا يعزز
سيطره روسيا على الاراضي المحتله اذا
بالحقيقه
كما لون كافئ روسيا على اعتدائها بدلا من
ان نتيح لاوكرانيا تحرير من هم تحت نير
الاحتلال الان لهذا سبب مبادرات سلام هذه
كلها قد تم رفضها حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك
من لندن كبير محلي للبرنامج روسيا
واوروسيا في المعهد الملكي لشؤون الدوليه
انتقد اكثر من مسؤولا روسي طلب رئيس
الوزراء البولندي انضمام بلاده الى برنامج
المشاركه النوويه على ضوء نشر روسيا اسلحه
نوويه في بيلاروسيا وقد ادت الحرب في
اوكرانيا الى تصعيد حرب تصريحات
والتهديدات الكلاميه باستخدام السلاح
النووي في الحرب الدائره في وقت تؤكد فيه
موسكو ان نقل اسلحتها الى بيلاروسيا هو
للردع والاستعداد للرد على هجوم محتمل
لكنها تحذر في الوقت ذاته من سباق تسلح
النووي غير منضبط
[تصفيق]
الحرب النوويه في اوروبا احتمال وارد ام
سيناريو يراد منه مصلحه لدول لا تملك
السلاح وترغب في نفوذه بوجوده على اراضهم
وان كان طلبوا وارسو ليس بجديد الا انه
كلما تجدد يحدث جدلا حديث رئيس الوزراء
البولندي
ماتيوسكي
المقرره في الانضمام الى برنامج المشاركه
النوويه لحلف شمال الاطلسي اغضب مره اخرى
الجرار روسيا ومن بين المنتقدين لتلك
التصريحات نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
بميتريف الذي كتب في التليجرام ان النشره
الاسلحه النوويه في بولندا يعني انها
ستستخدم
من جانبه علق على الموضوع نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
بالقول ان وضع معاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه لا يدعو للتفاؤل واصفا سباق
التسلح النووي بغير المنضبط وبان نتائجهم
ستكون كارثيه تبرر وسط طلبها بانه تحرك
لابد منه ردا على قرار الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين نشر اسلحه نوويه في
بيلاروسيا المجاوره قرار تمضي فيه موسكو
ومسك قدما استنادا الى احدث تصريحات
الرئيس الكسندر لوكيشنكو جزء كبير من
الذخيره النووي الروسيه بدا في الوصول الى
بلاده ويعتقد ان الاسلحه تتضمن مزيجا من
صواريخ اسكندر ان البالستيه قصيره المدى
وقنابل نوويه تلقى من الجو وفي كل مره
يؤكد الرئيس البيلاروسي ان النشره اسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه الروسيه في بلاده
يضف للردع اي معتد محتمل وانه لن يكون
هناك اي تردد في استخدامها اذا لزم الامر
تستبق اوكرانيا الاحداث ويهول رئيسها
من تهديد وخطر استخدام روسيا للسلاح
النووي في الحرب امام ضيفه الاسباني اتهم
موسكو بالتخطيط لاحداث تسرب اشعاعي في
محطه النوويه وتحميل بلاده المسؤوليه
قبل هذا التصريح كانت سلطتكيف اجرت
تدريبات في حال حدوث السيناريو الاسوا
رغبه وارسو في فتح ابوابها للسلاح النووي
لحلفائها الغربيين قد تتطلب تعديل
طائراتها المقاتله لاداء الدوري المطلوب
وايضا بناء المرافق الامنه المطلوبه
والاهم التي قابل تلك الخطوه قرر موسكو
فتح ابواب جهنم عليها السلاح النووي في
حرب اوكرانيا اداه تهديد ام ورقه توسع
لكسب معركه نفسيه في صراع تعدد الاقطاب
والمصالح ايضا
برنامج النيتو للاستخدام المشترك للاسلحه
النوويه اسئله بشانه وبشان مستقبل التنافس
النووي سنناقشها في فقره في المتابعه بعد
قليل
[موسيقى]
قال مراسل الجزيره ان مدينه نيالا غربيه
السودان شهدت قصفا مدفعيا متبادلا بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وكان
الجيش شنغارات على مواقع للدعم السريع
جنوب معسكر طيبه ومناطق التريعه والاعسال
وسليمانيه جنوبيه الخرطوم وقال مراسلنا
انه سمع دوي انفجارين قويين في جنوب شرقي
الخرطوم يرجح انها استهدفت مقر لقوات
الدعم السريع في المنطقه حسب مصادر محليه
تزامن ذلك مع اطلاق نار متقطعا من اسلحه
ثقيله جنوبيه الخرطوم كما اشار مراسل
الجزيره الى سماع يدوي انفجارات قويه
متتاليه جنوبيه مدينه ام درمان
في غضون ذلك قالت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان
قوات الحركه الشعبيه شمال بقياده عبد
العزيز الحلو هاجمت امس منطقه
السرافايا وسط اقليم جنوب كردفان ولم يصدر
تعليق رسمي من قبل الجيش بشان هذه
التطورات في ولايه جنوب كردفان
كما شهدت الحدود التشاديه السودانيه
وتوترا يوم امس عقب تبادلا لاطلاق نار بين
الجيش تشادي ومسلحين سودانيين قرن الباب
بلده اديكون الحدوديه وقالت مصادر في
الجيش التشادي للجزيره ان الحادثه وقعه
اثراء اصابه ضابط في الجيش التشادي برصاص
مسلحين سودانيين كانوا يطاردون سياره قرب
بلده اديكون واكدت المصادر ان الجيش
التشادي رد على مصادر النار واعتقل احد
المسلحين وارسل تعزيزات الى المنطقه قبل
ان يعود ويسحبها بعد ساعات من الحادث
قتل فتى تشادين نتيجه تبادل لاطلاق النار
بين الجيش التشادي ومسلحين السودانيين قرب
الحدود بين البلدين وقالت اسره الفتى ان
ابنها قتل برصاصا انطلقت من الحدود
السودانيه
على المستوى الانساني قالت وزاره الصحه في
بيان صحفي ان قوات الدعم السريع هاجمت
مستشفى الشهداء في منطقه
الدروشاب شمال بحري يوم الجمعه واطلقت
النار على احد الكوادر الطبيه ما ادى الى
وفاته واشار البيان الى ان القوه المهاجمه
اعتدت جسديا على الموجودين بالمستشفى من
مرضى ومرافقين وكوادر طبيه ودانت الوزاره
الاعتداءات على المؤسسات الصحيه والعاملين
في الحقل الطبي من جهتها نفذ قوات الدعم
السريع اقتحام قواتها للمستشفى ووصفت
الاتهامات بالمزاعم المضلله والكاذبه
والعاريه عن الصحه
في الاثناء حذرت مصادر طبيه سودانيه من ان
كارثه صحيه ستحل بمستشفيات وادي حلفا
شماليه البلاد بسبب نقص الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن
المصادر ذاتها ان الاطفال المرضى
بمستشفيات المنطقه يعانون ظروفا صحيه
بالغه الخطوره وكان مستشفى وادي حلفا قد
حذر من وقوع كارثه صحيه بين الاطفال في
مراكز الايواء بالمنطقه الواقعه على
الحدود السودانيه المصريه بسبب تفشي امراض
الاسهالات والالتهابات لا سيما التهابات
الجهاز التنفسي وتقدر الجهات المشرفه على
مراكز الايواء بالمنطقه عدد الاطفال فيها
بخمسه الاف طفل
انضموا الينا في الاستوديو خالد العيسير
الباحث والمحلل السياسي السوداني سيد خالد
مرحبا بك معنا اذا ما بدانا باحتدام
للمعارك في العاصمه الخرطوم مدن الخرطوم
الثلاث
ما الذي دفع الاطراف الى مثل هذه المعارك
ما الذي تريد ان تحققه على الارض
كان واضحا منذ لحظه الاولى ان قوات الدعم
السريع لا تريد ان تلبي اشتراطات الوفاء
مع عقدته من الاتفاقات ليس فقط على صعيد
اعلان جده وانما على التركيب الاساسيه
التي نشات بموجبه كقوات منوط بها حمايه
الامن والاستقرار في السودان وهي اقدمت
على خطوه 15 ابريل في سياق تحقيق اهداف هي
كغوات وغادتها ولم تكن هناك اجنده بخلاف
انها تريد ان تستاسر بمكاسب في السلطه
وبالتالي كل هذه الطرقات التي ترتكب الان
تاتي ضمن سلسله من الخروقات التي رسمت لها
السريع مع بعض نخوه القوه الخارجيه لكي
تتم في الخرطوم اما العمليات العسكريه
تاتي في سياق الرد والرد هنا يعود بالناس
الى الجهه التي هي منوط بها حمايه الامن
والاستقرار في السودان وفق الدستور كما هو
متعارف عليه والذي يقوي للجيش حمايه الشعب
السوداني هناك هذا يوحي بان المعارك على
الارض في مدن العاصمه تشيي بان هناك يعني
حاله عدم سيطره لكلا الطرفين والمراوحه في
ذات المكان وذات المربع من حيث ابتدات
الازمه عمليه القدر التي مارستها قوات
الدعم السريع في 15 ابريل كانت عمليه
مفاجئه وهي التي ابتدرت الحرب وهنا يجيب
هذا الامر يجيب على السؤال والمزاعم التي
ظلت تطليقها الدعم السريع منذ 15 ابريل
نيسان انها وجمت الواقع ان هاجمت والجيش
السوداني لم يكن في مواقع الهجوم كان
يدافع عن نفسه ويحسن المؤسسات التي يسيطر
عليها وبالتالي كان بديهيا ان يقوي الجيش
السوداني من مواقعه ويحصنه وينطلق انا
استطيع ان اؤكد لك ان عمليه الكرب والفرن
هذا المد والجزر الذي يحدث طوال الاشهر
الماضيه اصبح واضحا للعيان لكل مراقب ان
الجيش السوداني يحقق الانتصار تلو
الانتصار بين مقوات الصعب ما الذي يجري
الان هي الحرب التي اريدت الاراضي الدعم
السريعه ان تنطلق من عبر عبر الى السلطه
هي لم تكن فقط في الخرطوم كانت ايضا لديها
امتدادات في دارفور وشمال كردفان ولكن
الذي يحدث في دارفور ليس استثناء من الذي
يحدث في الخرطوم وهو سلسله الخروقات التي
ترتكب قوات الدعم السريع فيما يلي خطه
التي فشلت كل تاكيد وهي بالضروره ان تريد
ان تحسن مواقع في الاقاليم حتى ان يعني
تحقق مكاسب عسكريه تنطلق منها مره اخرى
لكزس مواقع على ارض الواقع لكي تهاجم من
جديد القوات المسلحه السوداني
في القطاع الطبي في المستشفيات مع كل هذه
الحرب واهوالها وتاثيرها على هذا القطاع
الذي يحذر من انهياره قريبا في اكثر من
منطقه تجري هناك انتهاكات واقتحامات
للمستشفى واتهامات متبادله من قبل الطرفين
لماذا يجري استهداف هذا القطاع القطاع
الطبي بهذه الصوره الاتهامات ليست متبادله
من قبل الطرفين الجيش السوداني هو الان
موجود في اكثر من 16 ولايه خارج الخرطوم
ويسيطر على السلطه بصوره كامله ولم تسمع
انه اعتدى على مستشفى في اي من هذه
المواقع مئات المستشفيات في الاقاليم اذا
الجيش السوداني لا يعتدى على المستشفى
اذا من الذي يقوم بذلك الشعب السوداني هو
الذي يتهم هو الذي هو شاهد عيان حي على
خروقات الدعم السريع وما ادل على ذلك الا
خروقات اليوم في مستشفى الشهداء في بحري
يا اقدمت على خطوه ايضا تتصل بجرائم ضد
الانسانيه في تعديها على الكادر الطبيه
وعلى المرافقين للمرضى والمرضى انفسه وهذه
سلسله من الخروقات التي ارتكبت قوات الدعم
السريع منذ اللحظه الاولى لعلك استمعتي
الى فكره ان نعتدد على المستودعات التي
تتصل بالمخ الاستراتيجي للقاح عشان
الاطفال في دارفور اكثر من مليون جرعه
سرقتها قوات الدعم السريع ودمرت المؤسسات
هذه ليست شهادتي ولا شهاده الحكومه
السودانيه ولا الجيش ولا حتى الشعب
السوداني وانما شهاده منظمه اليونسير في
العالميه المعروفه منظمه الصحه العالميه
ايضا وجهت بيانات تنتقد فيها سلوك قوات
الدعم السريع ازيدك من الكاس جرعه اخرى ان
قوات الدعم السريع قطعت الطريق على كل
الامدادات الطبيه التي وصلت في صياغ
المعونات الانسانيه والطبيه الدوائيه في
بورسودان واوقفت هذه المعونات قبل ان تصل
الخرطوم ومدن اخرى اذا هي تبرمج فكره
ليزراعه الحكومه السودانيه من خلال ضغطه
للمواطن السوداني حتى تحقق محاسب المنظمات
الدوليه التي هي معنيه اكثر من غيرها
بمراقبه هذه الانتهاكات التي تخص هذه
القطاعات قطاعات الطبيه والقطاعات التي
تخص الجانب الانساني هل توثق وتوصف الحاله
بطريقه منصفه لما يجري على نعود بك
وبالذاكره كل المشاهدين في هذه القناه
المحترمه الى
الازمات التي عقبت ازمه كورونا جائحه
كورونا كان هناك جدل كثيب على المستوى
العالمي حول فكره منظمه الصحه العالميه
وتقديما للمعونات الطبيه والدوائيه لدول
وحاله من الانتقائيه السوداني يتعرض
لمؤامره دوليه يشهد عليها القاصي والداني
ومن هذه الزاويه كانت هناك حاله من
الازدواجيه في التعبير عن حتى بيانات
الرفض والاستيجان ليس فقط في المحيط
العالمي البعيد عبر البحار وانما حتى في
المحيط العربي القريب والدول في الجوار
الاقليمي والافريقيه كانت تمارس حاله من
الازدواجيه وبالتالي المنظمات هي سياق
معادلات اموميه وتركيبه معقده لسياسه
الدوليه غير منظوره هي التي افرزت هذا
الواقع وهذا الدعم السريع كانت مخلب قط
لتمريض اجندات دوليه واقليميه ولكن الشعب
السوداني بحصافه وبقدراته التاريخيه
المعروفه يتحدى لهذه المؤامره التي فشلت
في الساعه الاولى والذي يحدث هو موجود
اجتهادات فاشله ستنتهي بالتاكيد
الباحث والمحلل السياسي السوداني ضيف نا
شكرا المشاركه
[موسيقى]
ونعود لاذا لنشاهد هذه الصور المباشره
تاتينا من باريس من جده الشانزليزيه وواضح
بان هناك انتشار امني وهناك
اذا توتر
وترقب لليله اخرى في فرنسا التي تابعنا
معكم
ليالي عديده هي الليله الخامسه اذا والتي
كانت قد اشتعلت فيها الضواحي في اكثر من
مدينه منها باريس مارسيليا اليوم
اذا
هذه الضواحي التي اشتعلت رافقت مع اعمال
عنف وشغب وايضا جرى الزج بالمزيد من اعداد
قوات مكافحه الشغب الى الشوارع المشاهده
بالصور مباشره من باريس
[موسيقى]
اذا نعود للحديث النووي الذي قفز للواجهه
مجددا عبر تهديدا روسي جاء ردا على
تصريحات كلانديه تناولناها قبل قليل في
الحصاد حيث طلبت وارسو الانضمام الى
برنامج الاستخدام المشترك للاسلحه النوويه
الخاص بالنيتو فما هو هذا البرنامج يؤكد
برنامج الناتو دوما على انه سيبقى تحالفا
نوويا طالما وجدت الاسلحه النوويه في
العالم برنامج الاستخدام المشتركه دفو
لضمان سياسه ردع النووي تمكن الاعضاء
الذين لا يملكون اسلحه نوويه خاصه بهم ان
يكونوا شركاء في القرار والاستخدام احيانا
هذه هي القوى الثلاث داخل الحلف التي
تمتلك اسلحه نوويه هي فرنسا بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده فقط الولايات المتحده
من بين هذه القوى ثلاث شاركت اسلحه نوويه
مع اعضاء اخرين في الحلف ونتحدث هنا عن
بلجكا المانيا ايرلندا
وايطاليا وايضا تركيا طبعا تسليمها لا
يعني ان للدول قدره على التحكم بها فهي
ففي اوقات السلم يخضع المخزون لحراسه
افراد من القوات الجويه الامريكيه وكذلك
الامر بخصوص الشفرات الخاصه بتشغيلها تكون
تحت السيطره امريكيه ولاوقات الحرب ان
تطورت في مسار النووي ترتيب اخر
في ارقام تقريبيه فان مجمل المخزون النووي
لدول الناتو ثلاث هو
راسا نوويا جلها في الولايات المتحده
فحصه فرنسا وبريطانيا مجتمعتين هي 500
وخمسه عشر راسا نوويا اما روسيا
فلديها نحو خمسه الاف وتسعمائه وسبعه
وسبعين وهو مخزون اكثر مما تملكه دول
الحلف نظريا ولكن اتحاد العلماء
الامريكيين قالوا ان تقديراتهم تشير الى
ان
10500 من هذه الرؤوس الروسيه ستفكك لانها
باتت خارج الخدمه للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من روما السفير اليساندرو
مينوتو ريزو نائب الامين العام السابق
للنيتو سيد اليساندرو مرحبا بك معنا بدايه
مثل هذا الطلب من قبل بولندا بهذه
المشاركه ضمن حلف الناتو للبرنامج
والاسلحه النوويه هل برايك ستلقى اذان
صغيره
بالسياقه ما يجري في بيلاروسيا
اعتقد انه يجب ان نشرح
بتفصيل الوضع والصياق لانه في الايام
الاخيره كثره الاخبار والكثورات
الارتباك والضياع اذا في الامس في نهايه
اجتماع المجلس الاوروبي في بروكسيل فان
رئيس الوزراء البولندي طلب بعض الاسلحه
التكتيكيه
النوويه
بحيث ان تدخل الاراضي البولنديه من اجل
ردعي ما تعتبره فنلندا تهديدا
بسبب الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه التي
تطورها روسيا في بيلاروسيا ولكن يجب ان
نكون حذرين في تقييمنا هنا لانها ليست
المره الاولى التي
يطرا فيها هذا الموضوع وليست المره الاولى
للتقول فيها بولندا
انها سوف يسرها ان تحظى بدعم من خلال
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه من دول الحلف كل مره
حين او طرح في هذا الموضوع في السنه
الماضيه كان الجواب بالرفض من قبل النيتو
من قبل الولايات المتحده وفي المتحده
وفرنسا حيث قالوا لا حاجه لوضع اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه او رؤوس حربيه نوويه في
بولندا الان
اختلف الوضع قليلا
بسبب
محاولات الانقلاب او ما نريد ان نسميه
تمردا ما نريد ان نسميه بسبب فاجنر
الاسبوع الماضي كما هو منتشر في الاخبار
فان
قائد مجموعه فاجنر وموجود الان في
بيلاروسيا في منزك وهناك اخبار وردات حول
ان مجموعه فاغنير تبني
مقرا خاصا بها في بيلاروسيا لهذا السبب
هناك تجدد في هذا الخوف من قبل بولندا
وكذلك ليتوانيا التي ايضا مجاوره
لبلاروسيا لا اعرف ما سيحصل في نهايه
المطاف ولكن برايه
ليس من السالي ان تكون الاسلحه نوويه
التكتيكيه
او ان تنقل الى اراضي قريبه جدا من روسيا
الا الا اذا في الايام المقبله حصلت او
وردت اخبار جديده عن اي تهديد محتمل حتى
الان هذا التهديد غير مراجع
مع وجود هذه الرغبه لدى بولندا وهناك
اتساع ايضا لهذه الرغبه بانتشار ونشر
الاسلحه النوويه الى اين سيقود دول اخرى
هي مهتمه ايضا بتطوير برامج نوويه حول
العالم
ويعني يجري الحديث ايضا عن رغبات في
الانضمام الى النوادي النوويه هذه هذه الى
اين سيقود مثل هذا الاندفاع
لدى هذه الدول ضمن سياق انتشار السلاح
النووي ومحاوله يعني
يعني التقليصه
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ليس بالامر
الايجابي حيث ان الاسره الدوليه تحاول ان
تتصدى لذلك ان تمنع
ظهور قوى نوويه جديده بقدرات نوويه
مستحدثه كما تفضلتم هناك عدد من الدول
التي تمتلك هذا السلاح ولكن هناك سؤال
مطروح حول موضوع ايران وحيازتها القنبله
النوويه ولا تزال المفاوضات تحصل بحسب ما
نعرفه احيانا طريقه رسميه واحيانا اخرى
بطريقه سريه بين اوروبا والولايات المتحده
من جهه وايران من جهه اخرى حرصا على ان
هذه القدرات النوويه هي فقط لاهداف مدنيه
وليس عسكريه يجب ان نكون
متوقدين وحذرين ولهذا اسباب وجيها من اجل
منع انتشار اسلحه دمار شامل في المدينه
الدول والا عاجلا ام اجلا سوف ياتي
دكتاتور غبي ويستخدمها وهذا سوف يدمر
كوكبنا
بما فيه انا وانتم وبالتالي املنا
هكذا طلب سوف يتم التصدي له لدينا الهند
لدينا باكستان تمتلك قوى نوويه اسرائيل
على الارجح مع ان الموضوع سري ولكن لا
اعتقد انه يجب ان نذهب ابعد من ذلك شكرا
لك من روما السفير اليساندرو منوتوريزو
نائبه الامين العام السابق لاني تحدثنا من
روما شكرا مشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]
بينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله نتوقف عند
الاعتذار الهولندي عن جزء من الحقبه
الاستعماريه وتحديدا العبوديه ارسم
استعماري وقفت وراءه دول عده وسلب فيه
عشرات الملايين من الناس حرياتهم وادميتهم
وكانوا اداه لبناء المجد والثراء حقبه
مليئه بالالم ولم يتوقف نزيفها واثارها
الا منذ عقود قليله بل ان بعض الاثار
مازال قائما في بعض الاماكن احيانا لا باس
بالاعتذار لكنه لن يكسر اغلال من ولدوا
عبيدا بلادا نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]